we have a voicemail number which is 219
to david p this is um
okay so this is the voicemail from the
san antonio troll
and he's calling with a cutesy little
fake accent
but he actually brings up some
interesting aspects that just again
prove the degree of
of lack of understanding that a lot of
these people have
now the san antonio troll has been
calling multiple times a week for months
trying to get on and i'm just so bored
with him that i've not been playing his
voicemails but there's actually
something instructive here so let's
listen and then discuss
hello pokemon um my name's tommy i'm a
long
time listener i love your show um
so i'm thinking pacman i like a lot you
know
our progressives we have the best ideas
they're better than everything we should
even share their ideas
all other ideas should be banned i know
you agree with me on this but um
what i'm thinking that's a progressive
you know a lot of the
the these racist right-wingers with all
races
um they think that uh the uh you know
that
we uh we're they're certainly not as
good we should prove them wrong
man you know how we're for reparations
we're for higher taxes
we're for staying at home and not
working why don't you stop working
and only collect a coca-chick why don't
you pay higher taxes out of your
paycheck and why don't you pay our
appreciation background i think if we do
that if we do it first
then other people will like agree with
us and stuff i don't know what do you
think awesome
so this is um i mean obviously this
person is very very dumb
but what's interesting about it is that
there there are people on the right who
seem to
not understand the point of society
and government and and culture and what
constitutes policy so that's a very
you know david if you which i don't if
you think people shouldn't work and
should just get coveted money
why don't you stop working and get just
live off of coved money well first of
all i didn't get any coveted money i
didn't qualify for any coveted money
that's first of all so i did i didn't
get any money
from anybody for first and foremost um
secondly why don't i just choose to pay
more taxes
uh that's not policy me me choosing to
pay more taxes
changes absolutely nothing that's not
how we govern that's not how
modern societies make decisions
me saying i'm gonna send the irs more
money which will mostly go
to defense spending anyway that's not
policy and that's not how how adults
actually govern
uh and then why don't i pay reparations
i mean i don't need
one of the trademarks of the san antonio
troll
is reacting to things i've not said
i've not advocated for people to start
paying reparations
i've said that i think it's a
politically difficult thing and
my my views on it are not set in stone
but this is not a show that has started
saying people start paying reparations
so
it's really important to understand and
you know the
i know that i'm taking total idiocy and
trying to actually
analyze it but there is something in
there that's important which is
if you believe the tax rate should be x
why don't you just start paying that tax
rate
and that is mind-numbingly naive and
also
extraordinarily childish in the context
of
that is not the way a society decides
what its priorities
are um and you know i'm not trying to
convince the san antonio troll but i
think it's important to keep this in
mind we have a great bonus show for you
today
stickers that signal whether you've been
vaccinated from covid
that could be the future and we're going
to talk about that number two
who did really well economically in
2020. we know like the uber billionaires
did really well
um but it's actually bigger than that
and we're going to talk about that on
the bonus show
and major development in the world of
electric vehicles
toyota has a game-changing new car
battery that is building on the
successes we've already seen from tesla
and others
and we could be looking in the next five
years at
extraordinarily dramatic changes in
terms of range and charging
speed and capacity for electric vehicles
which is exactly what it might take
uh to get electric vehicle adoption to
the next level and bring down prices
which is also very important
all of those stories and more on today's
bonus show and i will tell you about
today's
insane tech disaster which hopefully
you didn't notice we actually had one of
the biggest tech disasters today in the
last
probably two years of the show and i
think we cleaned it up
pretty well so i'll talk about that on
the bonus show as well get
instant access by becoming a member at
joinpakman.com